Nick Cannon throw shade at ariana grande
and waves in on Pete Davidson's rumored
new relationship with Kate Beckinsale
that's right during Wednesday's episode
of Wendy Williams the entertainer sat
down to talk all things hot Tom big and
it didn't take long for the guest host
to dive right into the biggest Hollywood
stories making headlines check this out
last night I was hanging out with my
little brother Pete Davidson we was in
Brooklyn
we was having cougar conversations
because
as I taught that young boy well of
course Nick was famously married to
Mariah Carey for eight years who is 10
years his senior and he didn't shy away
from saying he had a role in the 25 year
old romancing the 45 year old British
actress I'm gonna take credit for it I'm
the one that told him get you an older
woman man I said that leave leave look
pop stars alone oh the woman nowhere she
walks you don't play no games and that's
when Nick took a swing at his buddy's
ex-fiance the little pop stars they
don't know they're getting Japanese
menus tattooed on their backs I'm joking
but that is Ariana Grande's hand and I
think that's not that she even tried to
fix it so let's back up a little nick is
referencing Ariana's new Japanese tattoo
that was intended to read seven rings of
course we know that's a tribute to her
new hit song but well fans quickly
pointed out that it actually translated
to Chi cheering which is a small
charcoal grill that's a big mistake
oops that's some young girl stuff that
day you know uh you know older women
don't like tiny barbecue they like
chitlins and grits
this is of course a major change in tone
for Nick back in 2018 he was all about
Pete and Ariana when he sat down with et
he even revealed the SNL star called him
before asking for Ariana's hand in
marriage
he called you before it was gonna
propose to Ariana yeah he was really
excited I was like man I love it man
keep it going love is in the air have
you had a chance to congratulate them uh
yeah I congratulated Pete I haven't
spoken to Ariana but I mean I'm happy
for what did you think of this
engagement news I thought it was amazing
and I mean I watch them both grow up you
know Ariana has such a remarkable story
to sort of see them together and you
know I've been one of those dudes who
had those fantasy
fantastic relationships where you just
go up and get married do they seem like
they're a good pair together yeah
they're outstanding they're young people
in love you can't came back that it's
like the notebook Nick also said he'd be
down to officiate the wedding but he
didn't know quote how long it would last
if they let him do it of course we never
got to see that but who knows maybe Nick
can officiate for Pete and Kate should
their fling really get serious now that
would be fun the pair first sparked
bromance rumours in January when they
were spotted together at a Golden Globes
after-party and eyewitness told et at
the time that Kate and the comedian
spent at least an hour on a back patio
chatting and laughing together
saucy the two were photographed again
over the weekend holding hands as they
left a stand-up gig in West Hollywood
each he has independently confirmed that
the two are officially dating do you
like this couple I think that silence
says it all okay well let's hope that
Nick is a good luck charm for Pete and
Kay we know it didn't really work out
with him officiating Nick and Ariana's
wedding but of course be sure to
subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Halle underscore Stephens
and I met Courtney underscore teza know
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]